tian nerf de guerre froide au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies les
représentants américains et russes se
sont invectivés de part et d'autre de la
table lors d'une réunion à propos de
l'ukraine moscou avait d'ailleurs tout
fait pour empêcher que cette réunion ait
lieu le dialogue but toujours en public
en tout cas sur la présence de soldats
russes à la frontière ukrainienne
écoutez
les actes de la russie violent
profondément la charte de l'onu
c'est une menace claire et conséquente
pour la paix et la sécurité comme chacun
peut imaginer
si la russie est envahie l'ukraine aucun
d'entre nous ne sera capable de dire que
nous ne l'avions pas vu arriver et les
conséquences seraient terribles
nous comprenons parfaitement le désir de
nos collègues américains d'attiser
l'hystérie à propos de la soi-disante
agression russe
c'est une volonté qui s'exerce notamment
au sein du conseil de sécurité nos
collègues de ce conseil sont mis dans
une position très inconfortable
cette hystérie porte préjudice à
l'ukraine elle même